what have you found is the best way to
make money as a filmmaker i think you
know that's a tough question i
you know it's really important that
you know
obviously you know a lot of people i
think
forget that you know filmmaking
it you you have to pay people for what
they do because
there's a
you know there's a
[Music]
the thing in la that i've noticed a lot
is people tend to use uh exposure as
currency and i think that that
kind of becomes you know oh well you're
gonna get so much exposure if you do
this for free and for free and i think a
lot of people try and get freebies from
people but i think
making money as a as a
as a filmmaker is something that i don't
think ever gets easier
um
i think
you know you i always have to take side
jobs um you know editing jobs or jobs on
set um
and stuff like that or for example you
know i worked in a rental house and and
you know
whatever you can do that's going to pay
your bills that gets you the closest to
filmmaking and and movie making is is is
just as important
without naming names are you able to
share one of your worst jobs you know
you don't have to say of course where it
is we'd rather you not but it just what
you
yeah what the duties were and
you know i've i've had a lot of bad jobs
i worked um
the director i was friends with the
actor
and the the actor knew that i was a
director
and
the director of that actual project was
like this tyrannical
sort of intense you know he would
i think he thought that shouting and
yelling equaled you know direction and
and and
he was get we would get frustrated all
the time and we were we were traveling
all over the country
and uh there was one experience where
uh he my friend who was the actor was
trying to perform this scene
and he wasn't quite getting it the way
that the director wanted it
and
he came up to me because he knew i was a
director and he said what like what are
you what do you think and i was just
there as a as an ac i wasn't i was there
pulling focus i didn't want to get
involved in any of that stuff
but he was a friend of mine so i sat
there
i was like 20 i think at the time so i
was like well you know you know if you
maybe do this or
you know it might be more interesting if
you try this or that so he would try
those things and the director would just
get furious at him and was like
where are you getting this who is
telling all this information you know
and he would point right at me and say
oh ryan i was talking to ryan earlier
and he would tell and i'm just like no
so i got i got yelled at in a trailer
pretty intensely for a while about that
so there's i mean there's been some
really really bad you know you work with
a lot of people that that are
you know that that have
egos that don't
seem warranted um or necessary or even
earned to be honest um so a lot of the
sets that i've worked on have been
you know are pretty difficult and and
can be very difficult um but then you
know you work on great sets with with
amazing people and you you earn
a lot of amazing friendships that way
too
but i uh i still have some nightmares
from that
do you think that coming from another
state there were some unspoken rules
that it took a while to learn you know
because i know other states
you know even northern california
there's a different
way people approach people and just
learning that that unspoken culture yeah
it took some time the culture of like
filmmaking of like film sets and stuff
like that
yeah or and and just being in la and
whether to pick somebody a script that
you see it's well at a restaurant or you
know yeah i i think you know where i
grew up i was very isolated like i said
it was a very very small town um you
know i had one movie theater and
one
video rental spot and
so
the culture in that town was very
um
positive
uh it was very sort of like you can do
anything that you want to do and
and you can you know be anything that
you want to be and everybody was very
supportive so you had this sort of
community
i think i was like one out of
two people that wanted to make movies in
that town
so
there was this sort of culture of like
well you're the one guy that wants to do
this so everybody kind of if we do if we
need something like that done we go to
you so it was a lot uh sort of more
community oriented and friendly
and then you know moving out la it's
just there's just more people and
there's more
money and there's more
uh ideas and there's just it's so it's
it's a completely different culture to
the pacific north northwest as far as
just people go
um
i've never lived in a place with so many
people that's actually been so isolating
it's really interesting how isolating
los angeles can be
you know you there's this the glitz and
glamour of hollywood and you know you
have this
60 mile wide landscape of los angeles
that is actually really beautiful
and
you somehow feel just so alone when you
move out here you feel at least i did in
my experience i felt so
well i'm by myself and i got to figure
out how to do this and and and make it
work so so in that regards yeah they're
two very different cultures
and it is different culture film set
wise too i worked in a couple film sets
up in up in portland and
there is a there is a sort of a
a different vibe you know being small
fish
or i'm sorry being big fish in a smaller
pond up north
uh tends to drive more egos i think
whereas in my experience down here
there's a lot of fish but it's a huge
pond
and
though there are very egotistical people
there are
a lot of really really good people who
just
want to
continue to do what they love so i had
a very very different experience on film
sets down here versus versus up there
how important is it for you to quit a
day job so that you can put all your
time into filmmaking or is that not
something that's
important to you that's yeah i think you
know i think it's really important i
think it's easy to get
you know it's easy to get comfortable
um
excuse me especially
in a job like a rental house you know
it's very easy to sort of
sit there and go well you know i'm
getting paid i get to work with cameras
i get to do
for the most part be around the things
that i love and meet some really amazing
people
but i think it's really really important
that
if you can
to just
focus on what you love
and really really work
really really hard at it
and put a lot of time into it
and you know i think a day job is great
you know people you at the end of the
day we all have to pay bills and we all
you know we have to live
so
i don't think there should be any level
of of pride where you say well i'm not
going to take this job i'm better than
that or i'm better than
this i think that anything that's going
to allow you to continue to do what you
do
uh hold on to that
because for me it was very much working
at a rental house still allowed me to
make movies and work on the weekends and
you know meet people in the film
industry and make really really great
connections with people
um
but you know having not worked there now
being here full time and doing working
on my company full time in our movie
full-time
it's the most rewarding
uh thing that i i've ever done in my
life so far
so it's it's it's definitely important
to not lose sight of of what you love
but you know i get it it's you you have
to pay your bills and it's and it's
tough and and sometimes people i know a
lot of people work jobs they don't want
to work
and you know we've all been there so
was it also helpful with the rental
house that if something went wrong with
the equipment you could kind of file
that away and say okay
next time i need to yeah just i remember
this guy brought this back because this
happened or oh yeah definitely i mean
when you work in a roundhouse there are
you learn so much about the technology
and and you know these things are
you know
it is a technical process and and there
are people there that are just these you
know these gurus who know the ins and
outs of every little thing and and i was
very fortunate to be able to work under
them and learn the ins and outs of tons
of different camera systems and and as
well as you know i grew up on film so i
learned a lot of the majority of my
camera knowledge was film knowledge
because i learned
sort of
that film was kind of
the way to go and and and and so that
was my base understanding so digital
cameras was like this completely
different world to me
um but having spent time there and
working with them you know you do learn
a lot and so there was a lot of things
where you go
well you know this camera doesn't really
work that well in low light or this
camera you know we had this problem with
with this specific lens that we were
using let's try different lens next time
and so there's a lot of trouble it very
much allows for for troubleshooting and
learning and educating you know
you